يستعد هؤلاء الاطفال لمغادره مدينه صوب
مقاطعات روسيه اخرى اكثر امنا في اطار
اجراءات اتخذتها السلطات على خلفيه
التصعيد الذي تشهده المناطق الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا
واطفال اخرون ينتظرون دورهم في مركز
الايواء المؤقت هذا الذي انشئ الاستيعاب
مئات النازحين كما هو حال ايلينا وغيرها
ممن غادر قرىهم
[موسيقى]
غادرت عائله البلده في الصباح الباكر
وصلنا الى بلغراد والان سننتقل الى مسكن
مخصص لنا الوضع في البلده مرعب وصعب
والقصف لم يهدا على المنازل والبنى
التحتيه
تمكنا من الهرب قبل ثلاثه ايام عندما تجدد
القصف على البلده ما ان غادرنا حتى اشتد
وكما ترون انا مريض وبالكاد استطيع المشي
تقول السلطات الروسيه في بيل جورديناها
اتخذت كافه التدابير للتعامل مع موجات
النزوح المتواليه من البلدات الحدوديه في
اطار خطه شملت انشاء وتجهيز سته مراكز
ايواء كبرى
منذ بدات حاله الطوارئ الراهنه كنا
مستعدين لقد يحدث فتحنا بشكل سريع ثلاثه
مراكز ايواء مؤقته لاستقبال سكان شبكينو
مثلا جهزنا هذه القاعه لاواء 1125 شخصا مع
استمرار محاولات التسلل عبر الحدود من قبل
من تسميه موسكو مجموعات تخريبيه اوكرانيه
تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها تتصدى
باستمرار لتلك الهجمات وتوقع خسائر كبيره
في صفوف المهاجمين
بينما تتحدث وسائل اعلام محليه عن وصول
تعزيزات عسكريه الى المنطقه
وفي حين تتعرض المنطقه لقصف يسفر يوميا عن
سقوط ضحايا مدنيين
تشدد روسيا اجراءاتها باتجاه الحدود وسط
ازدياد المطالب بشن عمليه عسكريه باتجاه
مقاطعه خاركي فلوكرانيه لتامين اراضي
بيلغرود المتاخمه لها هذه الطرق المؤديه
الى المنطقه المتاخمه للحدود مغلقه جزئيا
حتى 30 من هذا الشهر اجراء جديد يضاف الى
اجراءات امنيه وعسكريه اخرى اتخذتها
السلطات لحمايه المدنيين من خطر القصف
وضبط امن الحدود والحيلوله دون حدوث
عمليات اقتحام جديده
امين الجزيره جنوب مدينه الروسيه